[Applause]
[Music]
it's Black History Month yay every
morning this month I wake up and look to
see what's waiting for me under the
Tubman tree will it be a white person
telling me what Martin Luther King would
have wanted or better yet someone saying
why do we need a Black History Month how
would you like it if we had a white
History Month you might be thinking
that's crazy the only reason we know
about such notable white achievements as
Betsy Ross is apparently groundbreaking
ability to use a needle and thread or
Paul Revere's remarkable ability to
scream and ride a horse at the same time
is because every month is White History
Month but hear me out
I think we do need a white history month
because the American history that's
taught in schools is so whitewashed we
don't learn the real story we learn lies
like George Washington chopping down a
cherry tree but not the fact that George
had 18 slaves before he turned 18. 18
slaves when I was 18 I didn't have 18
shirts I had three shirts and they all
look like this
each one of them cuter than the last we
learned that Abraham Lincoln said four
score and seven years ago but not that
he said I am not nor ever have been in
favor of bringing about in any way the
social and political equality of the
black and white races there must be the
position of Superior and inferior and I
am in favor of having the superior
position assigned to the white race they
don't put that on the penny partially
because it would make the penny too long
and partly because our schools don't
teach an honest version of American
history and that's why we need white
History Month history shouldn't just be
a list of names and dates it's supposed
to give us context for the present how
can we learn about Harriet Tubman and
Frederick Douglass and MLK's response to
inequality without understanding the
true history of the country that
enshrined that inequality into law for
example in regular history they tell you
the second amendment was created to
protect against tyranny but during White
History Month you would learn the truth
that the right to bear arms was added to
the Constitution so white men could keep
their slaves in check
that is a true fact see how much we're
learning White History Month is fun I
hope you're taking notes in your white
History Month Trapper Keeper
yes Martin Luther King
it's the day we look upon with happiness
and cheer get up and shout yay it's
Martin Luther King day it's the day we
remember what he was fighting for
a bunch of loves were made to keep black
people oppressed so black people
organized to try to clean this mess so
MLK said hey America we want civil
rights and they said maybe just not as
much as whites a lot of white people got
upset that we even dared to ask and
that's the really crazy part so let's
spend some time there they hated black
people so bad they couldn't sit next to
them on a bus and they didn't just go
away they're still alive and boating
like people always look at the Civil
Rights Movement as like this little bit
of time but it lasted forever
and it's still kind of going on
in theaters this spring
you've heard of Harriet Tubman's bravery
the way we're getting treated here will
not stand her courage and I have a plan
to get out
I'm gonna escape this Plantation her
fearlessness and then I'm gonna come
back for all of you finally a film that
tells the truth about what drove her to
Greatness and I'll tell you why I'm
coming back for you because I have a
dream to see black people free no to end
inequality not quite to destroy the
economic system that relies on our
enslavement for other people's profit no
nothing like that what is it then to be
on
the twenty dollar bill Harriet's dream
the true story of what motivated one of
the greatest women in history
[Music]
I can't run anymore yes you can go on
without me no I'm taking you North so
you can have a wonderful life so you can
get married and have children who have
children who have children who have
children and then those children those
children will be free no those children
will see my face on the twenty dollar
bill mmm
[Music]
the true story of her personal life
Harriet you don't have to keep going
back for them you've done enough enough
to be on the five maybe or the ten but
not enough to be on the 20.
what and the and the story of her Legacy
[Music]
studman I owe you everything
I'll honor your memory by working every
day of my life to end our oppression or
could you get my face on the 20. I don't
see how it's easy I made a prototype
you see it
coming this February it's the story of
an icon
follow me to Freedom yeah
yeah and when we get there let's change
the way money looks
Harriet's dream
why have real change when you can have a
symbol on a piece of paper
in the past few weeks several State
legislatures have introduced bills
Banning critical race Theory they've
done it in Georgia Tennessee Florida
Mississippi Oklahoma and a bunch of
other states where you can buy
Confederate flags at gas stations but
the thing is while some Americans are
Furious about critical race Theory a lot
of people don't even know what it is and
I don't blame them critical race Theory
sounds like the subtitle of a book
called Mario Kart for Dummies first I'm
going to pick up speed then I'm going to
throw some Nana's then I'm going to get
some coins and that is my critical race
Theory now in order to talk about
critical race Theory we're going to
start with something called the 1619
project the 1619 project is an
extraordinary Pulitzer prize-winning
work of Journalism conceived of by a
reporter named Nicole Hannah Jones it
was released to commemorate the 400th
anniversary of the arrival of enslaved
Africans in the colonies that would
become America that's right the first
anniversary is paper the fifth is wood
and the 400th is well researched and
award-winning journalism get to work
husbands one of the reasons the 1619
project has been so controversial is
that it proposes that we should talk a
lot more about the consequences of
slavery and the contributions of black
people when we talk about the
foundations of our country which of
course means acknowledging that racism
permeates our history because the fact
is right now kids aren't learning the
realities of our history in 2018 only
eight percent of U.S High School seniors
could identify slavery as the central
cause of the Civil War and that is
horrifying that's like only eight
percent of kids knowing you can make a
volcano with Mentos and Diet Coke
they're both basic facts now the good
news is that about two-thirds of
students do seem to know that the
Emancipation Proclamation freed the
slaves except and here's the thing it
absolutely did not do that that required
a whole Constitutional Amendment which
wasn't even ratified till after Abraham
Lincoln died in a horrible boating
accident
all the 1619 project was supposed to do
is help teach students about the role
slavery has played in American history
now some people claim that's rewriting
history and maybe it is but shouldn't we
revise things when we get better
information we used to prescribe cocaine
for toothaches now we know better and
it's mostly used so that former lacrosse
players can talk about crypto for seven
hours straight yeah you gotta have
Bitcoin bro
the point is as we learn more of course
we should adjust what we're teaching in
some parts of the country if students
learn black history at all they learn
that most Masters treated their slaves
kindly or slaves were given the
opportunity to become Christians instead
of remaining Heathen or that slaves got
to eat all the barbecue Pringles they
wanted
all of those things are equal parts
[__] but the first two are actual
quotes from a textbook that was used in
South Carolina for 130 years which is
probably why their current Senator
thinks that racism doesn't exist he
thinks it disappeared right around when
Daniel Boone killed all the dinosaurs
now this would be a great time for me to
tell you what we need to do to improve
our National History curriculum but
here's the thing we don't have a
National History curriculum every state
sets its own Teaching Standards think of
school curriculums like State mottos
every state has a different one and some
of them are batshit crazy Oregon state
motto is she flies with her own wings
that's not a motto that's a tagline for
a cicada biopic the fact is Most states
don't mandate a specific amount of black
history at all which is why most white
people only know about Harriet Tubman
Martin Luther King and Barack Obama even
worse twenty percent of them think that
that's Destiny's Child
if only there were some kind of say
prize-winning black history curriculum
developed by some of the greatest
scholars in the country I'm sure that
Americans would welcome it with open
arms and by arms I mean guns because it
turns out there are a lot of white
people who really don't want to learn
the truth about America and that finally
brings us back to critical race Theory
which is just a way of examining society
and history without pretending that
racism doesn't exist racism is part of
our past and our present it's been with
us for 400 years you can't squash it
into two sentences in a textbook between
the Civil War and the Roaring Twenties
you shouldn't fix history to make you
feel better learning about slavery feels
awful too bad try living with its
repercussions while white people tell
you there weren't any also it should
make you feel bad it should make you
feel so bad that you make sure nothing
like it ever happens again
critical race Theory gives us the tools
to examine our history in an open and
honest way and to fix the parts of our
educational system that aren't doing
that
[Applause]
[Music]